[Music]
fall has begun which seems like a good
time to look back on the big summer
america had
this year's black lives matter protests
created new alliances between
white americans and black americans and
with these new alliances we expected a
few failures but
what we ended up with is several big
fat juicy ones let's take a look at some
now in a segment called
colossal failures in our ship
june 8th 2020 a big bunch of
congressional democrats and other
members of congress
put on kante cloth and kneeled to
observe a moment of silence
in the capital's emancipation hall
making us all wish for emancipation
because i took one look at that and was
like get me out of here
that war can't take left to announce
sweeping legislation that aims to
increase police accountability
kente cloth is this a protest or a hbcu
graduation
let's break it down if you're dressing
like a black person to say
stop killing black people i mean why
good effort but were they out of black
lives matter t-shirts
nothing says stop killing black people
like a black lives matter t-shirt
i mean i love that you're trying but
this ain't it turns out
playing dress-up qualifies as a
colossal failure in allyship
that was me i did the voice the whole
time june
2020 instagram influencers don
blackface to support black lives matter
sorry can you get this out of here bye
no no yuck
now again dressing up like a black
person to show them you care about them
is not a thing but also how good did it
feel to be black for a minute
shoot i know all of the melanin none of
the oppression
until you leave the house one dirty look
from an old white lady for no reason and
i guarantee you will wipe that makeup
off with the quickness
so you tried it but it turns out
instagram blackface is a
colossal failure in allyship
august 30th 2020 the nypd hosts
a basketball tournament for families in
their community
sounds terrifying and i would never go
however that's not the bad part
the name of the event was pick up a
basketball
not a gun pretty crappy to assume these
black children had guns to put down
you know who needs to put down their
guns cops
that's like telling a bunch of residents
in a black neighborhood to turn on their
body cams
ooh note to self i need a bodyguard me
too also
i saw some footage and a butt ton of the
cops were minorities
now i'm not saying minority cops don't
do dirt of course they do
but we weren't worried about you black
people don't look at black people and go
ah a black person bang or there would be
no mirrors
so if you're gonna try to do good for a
neighborhood don't use a racist black
stereotype for the poster
sometimes what sounds like good
community fun is just a
colossal hair hazard
june 23rd 2020.
at a trump rally in arizona a young
student named reagan escude stood up at
a podium
and said the following aunt jemima
was cancelled and and if you didn't know
nancy greene the original first aunt
jemima she was a picture of the american
dream
she was a freed slave who went on to
be the face of the pancake syrup that we
love and
have in our pantries today you may think
that stopping people from getting rid of
a black spokesperson is being a good
ally but
that would be comically incorrect
the american dream doesn't have slavery
in it you idiot
also how condescending she is the face
of pancakes
that's a big achievement for a black
person
you know what you're the face of a
colossal
failure in nelly sheep
now i know being an ally can be tricky
there's stuff under here i'm kicking it
now i know being an ally can be tricky
but you got to try
even if i make fun of you so just
remember
no blackface no dress up no basketball
games based on stereotypes and
don't project your racist feelings onto
pancakes
if you follow those simple rules you too
can avoid a
[Music]
shop
you